[Music]
hi we're live from the Wolfram
technology conference I'm Silvia Haas
and I do the social media for Wolfram
research I'm here with my co-host hi I'm
Rena the student at the Illinois Math &
Science Academy and I'm part of the wolf
from emerging Leaders program we're here
with two teeth of energy I was a
research scientist at Wolfram and she's
here to talk to us about the neural
network
so what do you do all from so I work as
a research scientist in the machine
learning team and mostly I work in
applications of neural networks so I try
to code stuff up in the Wolfram language
was the important important research
that's happening out there so part of my
work is researching what's what's out
there and trying to bring the models in
the Wolfram language and then finally
making applications for our own
functions or adding stuff to the neural
net repository so what are you doing
here at conference so I I did a course
before on Monday so that was also on
mostly about neural net framework and
how somebody it was much more or less a
hands-on tutorial on how you make your
own application so custom applications
I'm doing this TED talk right now and in
3 hours 2 hours right from now I will be
giving another talk on importing neural
net models for the repository and
talking about the new thing that we have
made that's the oil index importer so
so tell us about some new things the
neural net positive so the net
repository is it's a it's a library of
pre curated models so a lot of our time
goes and identifying which models are
important and which aspects or which
feels and then trying to yeah and then
coding them up or importing them into
the repository testing them making sure
that it's correct and making examples so
that it's easier for our users to just
directly use them so what's me you I
guess I'll be talking a little bit about
the most important models and then I'll
be giving an overview of all models that
we have added since the last version
released which was in April and that
comes to us the NLL just like so flashy
pictures of what's there and what we can
expect in the near future in like next
two weeks or so so we will get some code
so yeah so let's look at some of the
important models that's out there so a
big thing that happened in NLP natural
language processing research was what's
called good so but is bi-directional
encoder transformer so bi-directional
and coded representations from
transformer but I really liked it in a
funny way so we take the meme from the
actual foot and then just add a
bi-directional friendship because it
goes both ways so the thing about
bi-directional encoding means it's it
goes so if you read text it goes forward
and backward and that's why
bi-directional so this one was a very
famous model that came out and it's sort
of broke all the state-of-the-art
accuracies so here is like I just put
the table of like all the kinds of data
set and all the kind of tasks where but
sort of overpowered every other model so
that's why it was the importance model
and we decided that we need this model
in the repository so but in the
repository it is so we also introduced
what's called the parameterize neck
models in the repository since we were
seeing that they were exponential number
in the number of models that keeps being
added and they just differ by a little
bit of parameters so we decided to keep
all the parameters under one name so
that it gets less confusing for our
users so it's so as you can see the part
is kept as like you can call Bert as a
neck model and then you can ask for
different parameters so it's like these
parameters or the different allowed
values just directly come from the paper
so it's cased uncased large and base
models and also the type of inputs also
you can change so this is how you would
ask for parameter information from the
neck model again I'll be speaking a
little bit more about the parametric
models in my talk so I'll keep it short
and you can ask for whichever model you
choose so you can have a permutation and
combination of what parameters you ask
for so I'll go ahead and try to explain
a little bit about the architecture of
again this is one of the more famous and
very complicated architecture so I might
not do a very good job in two or three
minutes but I still give it a try so but
again
so each neural-net model in the Wolfram
language has what's what we call a net
encoder that is what so whatever inputs
data type you have you have to convert
it into tensors so net encoder is what
converts the input type to tensors so
for boy it's a text so it's a natural
language processing thing so you have a
text so you need to convert it into
words and sub words and that's what's
done by this net encoder forward again
this is a custom net in order not one of
the built-in ones so we built the net
and go to ourselves and you can just
query you can extract that encoder from
the model and play with it or change it
for your own applications so that's that
the encoder part and we can just see
like what the encoder does as you can
see it takes the string and converts it
into numbers so there are two kinds of
encoding one is for the word and one is
for the sentence so as you can see this
of course in second sentence and it does
accordingly
so once the embeddings are done you can
actually do a matrix plant
not that it makes any sense right now
but you can just visualize the
embeddings and all of them so so one
thing to note is they have special token
for T start and end of the sentence
that's the position and then you have
positional a disease as well so that's
all with the embedding so what embedding
does is take the text and converts it
into numbers and there you go that's the
embedding done but the main architecture
of word is the what's called the
transformer architecture so that's why
it's the bi-directional transformer so
the transformer architecture has so it's
interesting because it introduces a new
paradigm of architecture so that's
what's called the attention multi-headed
attention so the good thing about neural
about the neural net framework in
machine
Mathematica language is that you can
just click and visualize all the
complicated architecture so I think this
has more than 800 or so layers but it is
all compressed and all you see is like
little block blocks where you just like
click on it and like a child you can
sort of play with it and understand
what's the architecture I think that's
what's fascinating about the about the
framework that we have here so as you
can see that each of these have
attention players in this particular
model there are 12 blocks of these
multi-headed attention again if you
click on them you can go ahead and see
that they are made with what's called
the attention layer so building these
architectures from the bottom up is what
we have done to get the model here but
again here we we are trying to show that
but it uses self attention so there are
two kinds of attention one a self
attention and the other is partial
attention so self attention as I was
saying it's bi-directional so you have
as you can see you have connections from
both the quotes forward and backward is
nine and you also have Gaussian
retention which goes on forward in time
so we will see an example of that in the
next model that I talked about but just
to give an overview of words so Bert is
one of the best feature vectors that you
have so it's it's good that I show an
example where the feature vector like we
can use word as a feature vector so we
are doing a sentiment classification
with the bottom bearings and here you
can see that I'm taking an already
existing data set in the Wolfram
language so we have the said that takes
a bunch of next so movie reviews which
users have given and classifies them as
positive and
and what we will do is we will take
three different kind of hem bearings
three different kind of models that's
already there in the repository the
clove one which doesn't have any context
Elmo which which had a context so it
knows from reading the sentences not
just the words so it has a context a
bird again has context and it is
bi-directional so it just knows it
learns the features better so what we
are doing here is making a sentiment
classification from all three models I
will skip the details of the code a bit
just going saying that we are using the
same sort of code for making the
classifier modified just the embeddings
part of it is different coming from
different models and as you can predict
that for being the best feature vector
it achieved the lowest error rate so it
got around 15% while clove and elbow
gave around 24 and 19%
so that was the end of 2018 and then we
have the next to medium where we say oh
the NLP researchers so if you don't get
this meme like the bird is here and then
anything we saw just turned their turn
their head or move their attention which
makes more sense here because we are
talking about attention models attention
based models so they turn their
attention to something with unicorns and
if you don't get the reference here
that's also pi because when GPG 2 came
out the first block of text gptt was a
language model and then they gave this
model of very funny reference that says
in a shocking findings scientists
discovered a herd of unicorns living in
a remote previously unexplored Valley in
the Andes mountain who happened to speak
in English and then there they let just
the models just output what it had and
the output of the modulus would be 20 so
I wouldn't be able to read that out loud
because of time constraints what I ask
everyone that is a funny thing
so what I did here was to take the
reference and modify the example of
which to to to get outputs here so we'll
take the GPD to transformer the larger
one and en-gb t2 is placed in same way
as port so I wouldn't go into the
details but I would just assure the
language modeling aspect of it which is
important for this model so it's very
similar to word it has encoders there
are technically they are different so
they do they use different kind of
encoding function but we are not going
into the details it uses vp suffered to
do its encoding there is still the
positional index there is still the
token index the vocabulary is a big
better than the boat model and the only
difference between Bert and GPT too is
what we are saying the firt was our
encoder the encoder transformer and DVD
do is a decoder transformer and the
difference is the kind of the tensions
or but had self attention this has
causal attention so that's the
difference and I have pointed the
difference in pink because we had all
unicorn reference so and then we go
ahead and do text generation with GPD do
so I just just take the GPT to model and
give what's called temperature so
temperature is something which so if you
think of the entire vocabulary as a
distribution temperature says how flat
of a distribution you are sampling from
so if you if you are sampling from a
thinner distribution then your
temperature will be lower flatter
distribution of the temperature is
higher so here we just show examples I
just took the same thing and modified it
a little bit just took away the names of
the mountains and just just modified it
a little bit to show what happens if you
change the temperature and the and the
sampling of it
so that's what you get and again they
they make it makes hurts it just
continues it and says according to the
team 50 unicorns lived in 16 rectangular
structures that range from 15 which are
depleted finish
so as you can see if I increase the
temperature it becomes a little bit more
Riyadh that's what we expected and then
when I decrease the probability it says
the researchers also found that the
unicorns weren't able to communicate
with each other through their thumbs and
that repeats because it's sampling
distribution so that is what happens if
you eat less temperature it just get
stuck in the same it's get stuck in
around so that's that's what I was
that's the more important model that we
have we have some other little little
models that I can just let go I was
saying that we have introduced the
parametric net model so the reason why
is because we've a lot of different
models so these are just two claims of
other models that we have so this is a
segmentation model for Biological image
segmentation this is a resolution
enhancement model this is a sentiment
analysis model so that's also based on
LST ms before encoders very thing this
is the mobile length model so these are
much smaller models than it was before
and this is a PPE model and I think this
is auto model the from how do you
identify model that we had in hangar 12
so these are the just a list of
different models that we have right now
in the pipeline but
to be which is either in the repository
we are curating it or we are in the
process of getting them out so we also
encourage our users to submit models to
the repository so that's why I put the
last slide here it's because all of
these models the four models you see
here but not done by us they were
submitted by the by our users and then
we we curate them and make sure it
follows our standards I encourage all
thank you much for coming and talking to
us
coding needs more unicorns in it
[Music]